he's on that screen he's in the bedrooms  of all those women telling them good and  bad  and they love him he came into a place  where we had a lot of women sitting  there waiting for something unrelated  they started going crazy is that Dr Oz  that's Dr Ross yeah so Trump seemingly  jealous I guess of uh the effect that  Oz's show has on women now in all  seriousness the entire rally was  supposed to be for Oz and there was  actually quite a bit of booing whenever  his name would come up it doesn't seem  the Trump crowd is necessarily sold on  Oz my friend Dr Mehmet Oz he's a great  man  and even a bunch of people interviewed  before the rallies said that I am not  sold on Oz here